so we kinda have a health crisis that's
causing an economic crisis or kind of a
shock as you described it there's a lot
of economic policies that have been
implemented what's kind of your general
view of what's already been done and
maybe even what needs to be done in the
future right so you know my mentor is
art Laffer I don't know if you're
familiar with the Laffer curve
supply-side economics but he advises
Trump president Trump informally
regularly and I know because I hear
during the taskforce briefings I hear
some of the things that art Laffer says
coming out of President Trump's mouth in
the beginning art was very frustrated
that they were just throwing money at
this just willy-nilly and effectively
effectively throwing money at the idea
that we don't want people to work and
from from one point of view that was
correct we wanted people if they could
to work from home of course but we
wanted them to be safe first and
foremost they had as so the the programs
that were being designed in the early
days and we're just throw the money at
them have been modified so that you're
seeing more in the form of loans to
small businesses and others that will
have to be repaid after a long grace
period so that is good just to keep the
infrastructure in place to keep the to
allow the employment to rebound
afterwards instead of unlike in a recent
recession where you have capital
destruction you it takes a long time to
work through it and then to come back so
I think that's good I think it's good
that they are sending checks out to
those who can't we're living paycheck to
paycheck but I think a more important
way to help those people and would have
the same effect would be to say and I've
heard president Trump mention it
I've been put into any legislation yet
to basically go on a payroll tax holiday
both both for the employers and the
employees through the end of the year
what would that do it would say it would
encourage businesses who are getting
these holidays and employees to get back
to work as quickly as it possible to
take advantage of the holiday and
increase their returns by six to seven
percent on either side that's huge
that's the tax wedge that art Laffer
talks about all the time if you get rid
of that wedge you bring a lot more
activity back much sooner than otherwise
would be the case and I think the other
in terms of the way they're treating
larger corporations I think they're
creating inducements to Rev back up
faster what they're doing is they're
saying okay if you take these loans then
you cannot buy buy back shares or pay
dividends for a year past when and I
don't know if the legislation has
changed your a bit but this is how it
was being written a year past the day
you repay those loans well what what
will that cause shareholders certainly
will want their companies to to get back
on track much faster so they can pay
back the loans to the government and
then get back to paying dividends which
for many people are a large chunk of
their of their income especially a
retirees and to repurchase shares which
favors all shareholders so I think
they're doing these are they're
gradually getting it right and very
sensitive you hear more and more about
you hear certainly the president and the
vice president talking about getting
people back to work safely so you'll
have pent focused on the safety and
you'll have Trump focused on getting
back to work and it's a good dynamic and
an important dynamic I think yeah are
you worried at all
you know we're in a deflationary
environment now there's a lot of QE
going on are you one worried that we
could over rotate on the inflationary
side when we switch back and are there
any impacts that you foresee potentially
on the US dollar it's kind of a global
asset or reserve asset mm-hmm okay so
the first question and when we can and
we can take some of we can inform the
answer that question partly by what
happened after Oh 809 so I remember when
you know it was QE everything you know I
remembered being concerned saying wow
this is just such an inducement to take
a lot of risk and just go out there and
go for it that's not what happened what
happened was people were so traumatized
by the near breakdown of our financial
and economic system that they were not
sure we were going to be able to hold
together and you know there are all
kinds of uncertainties including what
became the election year you know we had
the European sovereign debt crisis we
had in 16 oil prices crashing like they
have recently and China seeming to
implode and so every step along the way
there was a reason for people to hold
back and not throw everything that they
have at risk-taking and in fact the loss
the velocity of money which is the
critical answer here has been falling
and my guess is falling at an
accelerated rate now and so all of that
QE most of it is still sitting on the
balance sheets of central banks now the
way I think about that still is that is
kindling for the fire potential fire
that you're talking about but that
kindling hasn't been lit for the past 10
years because every step along the way
including the china-us trade conflict
and the inverted yield curves everyone
of those steps along the way has been a
reason to recoil and say so the velocity
of money has continued to come down now
we have m2 today growing at a 15%
year-over-year rate which is I believe
the fastest I mean you have to go back a
lot of years to see that I think many
people have gotten used to this idea
that we can throw anything we want at
the system and velocity will fall and
offset it there will be come a day and
this could be the beginning but I don't
think it well I don't think we'll see
the ramifications in terms of inflation
for I'm going to say at least a year and
a half maybe two years because first we
still do have a little bit of this
seizing up and people saying is my job
going to be there so that's one reason
and business is the same is my business
going to exist so again another reason
if you look I just listened to the JP
Morgan call this morning and you know so
many businesses have taken down their
revolvers completely you know so they
are just awash in cash their own wash in
cash and they did the same thing in a
809 but again nothing happened everybody
being scared every step along the way so
the reason we won't have an inflation
problem for the next 18 months two years
there are two reasons one oil prices
have crashed and oil is a big part of
you know the input and and there's a
good reason secularly for oil to crash
we talk about it all the time
I think oil is going down longer-term to
ten dollars or less per barrel and I've
been saying that for a while that's a
personal point of view and that's
because of electric vehicles and
autonomous electric vehicles at the
margin gas powered cars are going to
start losing out and commodity prices
are determined at the margin that's what
a lot of people miss when they say oh
well electric vehicles are only two
percent of all sales no they're a much
higher percentage of the growth in the
auto industry
right so so the first reason is that
major input to so many industries the
second is typically if we're going to
have a v-shaped recovery what will
happen is productivity will search now
productivity was already starting to
search so again this idea forces in
motion continue in motion
I think the accelerated shift into new
technologies now is going to cause an
acceleration in productivity growth
we're probably going to see productivity
growth numbers in the next year that we
haven't seen I'm gonna say since the 60s
so that's that's another reason
productivity is a huge force against
inflation because why because a company
which benefits from productivity can do
three things with it
it can increase wages so if they--if
come if companies have labor shortages
they will increase wages but not now
nobody has labor shortage because the
unemployment rate is going to go to 15%
or whatever or higher it can go to lower
prices to compete and bring consumers
back and to compete against China
because China is using innovation and
deflation to compete so that's another
thing that could happen here which would
reinforce this disinflationary cycle or
it can go to increase profit margins and
it's probably going to depending on the
industry going to go to all three so I
don't think what's the inflation in the
near term I do worry about it now that
no one thinks it's possible anymore
I remember starting at the business that
was the late 70s I was in college and I
remember looking at these CPI numbers
that were coming out and economists
didn't didn't believe them because they
thought inflation had been licked
then when really it had just started
because we went off the gold exchange
standard in 1971 but no one could
believe the numbers we were seeing
that's because they had been lulled into
complacency that the Fed could do
anything it wanted well I think that
we're back in that situation but we will
not face and I know where you're going
with this obviously Bitcoin we won't
face the real ramifications for another
couple of years but you know I know
we've increased our Bitcoin exposure
we're in the discretionary portfolios at
arc and I think I think it's the right
thing to do from an insurance policy
point of view yeah well we'll never get
to get two big countries